bien avant l'échéance.
Cela prouve que l'espèce humaine
peut arriver à d'extraordinaires progrès
en se montrant unie et persévérante.
Mais en ce moment,
j'ai l'impression que la mondialisation
nous a pris par surprise,
et que nous y avons réagi lentement.
Si l'on regarde ses inconvénients
C'est vrai que ça peut sembler accablant.
Tous les problèmes auxquels nous faisons face,
comme le réchauffement planétaire, les droits de l'Homme,
la surpopulation, le terrorisme, les épidémies,
le trafic de drogue, l'esclavage,
la disparition des espèces, et plus encore ;
nous ne progressons pas beaucoup
sur beaucoup de ces problèmes.
En bref, c'est le problème
qui se pose à nous tous
en cette période-clé de l'histoire.
C'est ce que nous devons faire.
Il faut que nous arrivions à nous reprendre
et trouver comment améliorer
la mondialisation des solutions
pour éviter de devenir une espèce
victime de la mondialisation des problèmes.
Mais, alors, pourquoi notre progrès est-il si lent ?
Quelle en est la raison ?
Bien sûr, il y a plusieurs raisons,
mais c'est peut-être surtout
parce que notre espèce est toujours organisée
de la même façon
qu'il y a 200 ou 300 ans.
Il y a une superpuissance sur Terre :
les sept milliards que nous sommes,
qui créent tous ces problèmes,
les mêmes, d'ailleurs,
qui les régleront tous.
Mais comment ces sept milliards sont-ils organisés ?
Ils sont toujours organisés en environ 200 États-nations,
et les nations ont des gouvernements
qui créent des lois
et nous font nous comporter d'une certaine façon.
Et c'est un système assez efficace,
sauf que la façon de créer ces lois
et la façon de penser des gouvernements
ne permettent pas de résoudre des problèmes globaux,
parce qu'elles se centrent sur leur nation.
Les politiciens élus,
et ceux non élus, en général,
regardent dans un microscope.
Pas dans un télescope.
Ils se concentrent sur eux-mêmes. Ils prétendent, se comportent,
comme s'ils pensaient que chaque pays était une île
qui vivait heureuse et indépendante
de toutes les autres
sur sa petite planète à elle
dans son petit système solaire.
Voilà le problème :
des pays en compétition,
des pays en guerre.
Cette semaine, comme toujours,
vous verrez des gens essayer de s'entretuer d'un pays à l'autre,
et même quand ce n'est pas le cas,
les pays sont en compétition,
chacun essayant de rouler l'autre.
Ce n'est pas une bonne situation.
Elle ne peut pas durer.
Nous devons trouver des façons
d'encourager les pays à collaborer
d'une meilleure façon.
Et pourquoi ne le font-ils pas?
Pourquoi nos dirigeants persistent-ils dans cette approche égocentriste ?
Tout d'abord, évidemment,
c'est que nous le leur demandons.
C'est notre message.
En élisant un gouvernement
ou en tolérant un gouvernement illégitime,
nous leur disons que ce que nous voulons,
c'est qu'ils arrivent à certaines choses
dans notre pays.
Nous voulons qu'ils assurent la prospérité,
la croissance, la compétitivité, la transparence, la justice,
etc.
Si l'on ne demande pas à nos gouvernements
de changer un peu d'approche,
de réfléchir aux problèmes qui nous tueront tous
si nous ne les réglons pas rapidement,
alors on ne peut pas vraiment leur reprocher
de continuer à se centrer sur eux-mêmes,
à regarder dans un microscope
plutôt que dans un télescope.
C'est la première raison du peu de changements.
La deuxième, c'est que ces gouvernements,
tout comme nous tous,
sont des psychopathes culturels.
Ne le prenez pas mal,
mais vous le savez.
Un psychopathe est quelqu'un qui,
malheureusement,
n'a pas la capacité de compatir
avec d'autres êtres humains.
Autour d'eux,
ils ne voient pas des semblables,
avec des vies remplies, à trois dimensions,
des buts et des ambitions.
Ils voient des personnages en carton,
ils se sentent tristes et seuls,
et heureusement, c'est très rare.
Mais, en fait, ne sommes-nous pas, pour la plupart,
pas très bons pour l'empathie?
Si, bien sûr,
quand il s'agit de personnes
qui nous ressemblent,
marchent, parlent, mangent, prient
et s'habillent comme nous,
mais pour les autres personnes,
qui s'habillent différemment,
prient différemment,
et parlent différemment,
n'avons-nous pas la même tendance
à les voir comme des personnages en carton ?
Il faut se poser cette question.
Je pense qu'il faut sans cesse se demander
si nous ne sommes pas, d'une certaine façon,
des psychopathes culturels.
Troisièmement, c'est bête,
c'est ridicule,
mais nos dirigeants pensent
que l'agenda national
et l'agenda international
sont incompatibles et le resteront.
C'est du grand n'importe quoi.
Je suis conseiller politique.
J'ai passé les 15 dernières années
à conseiller divers gouvernements,
et, pendant ces années, jamais je n'ai vu
un seul problème national
qui ne pouvait être résolu de façon plus inventive,
plus efficace et plus rapide
qu'en le traitant comme un problème international,
en se tournant vers l'international,
en regardant ce que les autres font,
en se tournant vers l'extérieur
plutôt que vers l'intérieur.
Vous allez me dire, eh bien alors,
pourquoi ça ne marche pas ?
Pourquoi nos politiciens ne changent-ils pas ?
Comment les y obliger ?
Comme tout le monde, je passe beaucoup de temps à dire
qu'il est difficile de faire changer quelqu'un,
et nous ne devrions pas nous en plaindre.
Nous devrions accepter
d'être une espèce conservatrice par nature.
Nous n'aimons pas le changement.
C'est la conséquence logique de notre évolution.
Nous n'existerions sûrement plus aujourd'hui
si nous n'étions pas si anti-changement.
C'est tout simple : il y a des milliers d'années,
nous avons découvert qu'en continuant
à faire les mêmes choses, nous pourrions survivre,
car ce que nous avons fait par le passé
ne nous a bien sûr pas tués,
et donc en continuant à faire de même,
tout ira bien,
et refuser le changement est logique
puisqu'il pourrait nous tuer.
Mais, bien sûr, il existe des exceptions,
sinon, on n'avancerait jamais.
Et on est dans un cas exceptionnel
quand on arrive à montrer
qu'il pourrait y avoir un intérêt personnel
à faire ce saut dans le vide
et à changer un peu les choses.
J'ai donc passé ces 15 dernières années
à chercher quel pourrait être cet intérêt personnel
qui n'encouragerait pas que les politiciens
mais aussi les entreprises et le public,
nous tous, à penser un peu plus vers l'extérieur,
à voir les choses d'un peu plus loin,
de ne pas regarder uniquement vers soi, mais aussi vers les autres.
Et c'est là que j'ai fait une découverte
assez importante.
En 2005, j'ai lancé une étude,
l'indice des marques nationales.
C'est une étude à grande échelle qui pose des questions
à un grand échantillon de la population,
un échantillon représentant environ 70%
de la population mondiale,
et j'ai décidé de leur poser des questions
sur leurs perceptions des autres pays.
Et l'indice des marques nationales
est alors devenu une immense base de données.
On a récolté environ 200 milliards de données
reflétant ce que les gens ordinaires pensent des autres pays
et pourquoi.
À quoi bon ? Parce que les gouvernements que je conseille
veulent vraiment savoir
comment ils sont perçus.
Ils savent, notamment parce que
je les ai incités à le comprendre,
que les pays dépendent
énormément de leurs réputations
afin de survivre et de prospérer dans le monde.
Si un pays jouit d'une bonne image,
comme l'Allemagne, la Suède ou la Suisse,
tout est facile et rien n'est cher.
Il y a plus de touristes. Plus d'investisseurs.
Vous vendez vos produits plus chers.
Par contre, si vous avez un pays
avec une image très faible ou négative,
tout est difficile et tout est cher.
Les gouvernements s'inquiètent donc
de l'image de leur pays,
car elle influence directement
leurs rentrées d'argent,
et c'est ce qu'ils se sont engagés
à fournir à leur peuple.
Il y a deux ans, j'ai décidé de faire
une pause et de m'adresser à cette immense base de données
et de lui demander
pourquoi certains préfèrent un pays
à un autre.
La réponse de la base de données
m'a complètement sidéré.
C'était 6,8.
Je n'ai pas le temps d'expliquer en détail.
En gros, ce qu'elle m'a dit, c'était...
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
les pays que nous préférons sont les bons pays.
Nous n'admirons pas un pays parce qu'il est riche,
puissant, ou qu'il a du succès,
parce qu'il est moderne, à la pointe de la technologie,
nous admirons surtout un pays parce qu'il est bon.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire ceux qui contribuent
au monde dans lequel nous vivons,
les pays qui rendent le monde plus sûr,
meilleur, plus riche ou plus juste.
Voilà ceux que nous aimons.
Cette découverte est capitale,
vous voyez où je veux en venir,
parce que ça règle le problème.
Je dis désormais aux gouvernements
« pour réussir, vous devez faire le bien. »
Si vous voulez vendre plus,
obtenir plus d'investissement,
si vous voulez devenir plus compétitif,
vous devez bien vous comporter.
Ainsi, vous gagnerez le respect,
et on voudra faire des affaires avec vous.
Donc, plus vous collaborez,
plus vous devenez compétitif.
C'est une découverte assez importante,
et dès lors,
j'ai senti qu'il fallait un autre indice.
Plus je vieillis et plus mes idées sont simples
et enfantines, apparemment.
Celui-ci s'appelle « l'indice des bons pays »,
et tout est dit dans le titre.
Il mesure, ou du moins essaie de mesurer,
la contribution exacte de chaque pays,
pas à ses propres habitants, mais au reste de l'humanité.
Étrangement, personne
n'avait pensé à le mesurer avant.
Mon collègue Robert Govers et moi-même
avons donc passé ces deux années,
avec l'aide de nombreuses personnes très sérieuses et intelligentes,
à rassembler toutes les données fiables nous indiquant
ce que les différents pays offrent
au monde.
Et vous voulez que je vous dise lequel se démarque.
Et je vais vous le dire,
mais d'abord je veux expliquer
ce que j'entends exactement
par « bon pays ».
Je ne parle pas de bien moral.
Si je dis que tel ou tel pays
est le « plus bon » pays au monde,
et pas le « meilleur »,
« meilleur », c'est différent.
En parlant d'un bon pays,
il y a « bon », « plus bon » et « le plus bon ».
Ce n'est pas « bien », « mieux » et « meilleur ».
C'est un pays qui, tout simplement, donne plus
à l'humanité que tous les autres pays.
Pas ce qu'ils font chez eux,
ça c'est mesuré par d'autres indices.
Et le grand gagnant est...
L'Irlande.
(Applaudissements)
Selon les données que j'ai ici,
aucun pays dans le monde, que ce soit par habitant,
ou par dollar de PIB, ne contribue plus
à notre monde que l'Irlande.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Ça veut dire qu'avant de s'endormir,
quelques secondes avant de sombrer,
on devrait tous se dire :
« Mince, heureusement qu'il y a l'Irlande. »
(Rires)
Et ça... (Applaudissements)
Alors que nous traversons une grave récession économique,
je pense qu'il y a vraiment une leçon à en tirer :
arriver à honorer ses devoirs internationaux
tout en reconstruisant sa propre économie
ça force l'admiration.
La Finlande est très proche.
Elle est derrière l'Irlande
parce que son plus bas score est inférieur à celui de l'Irlande.
Une autre chose à propos de ce top 10 :
tous ces pays, sauf la Nouvelle-Zélande,
sont des pays d'Europe occidentale.
Ils sont également tous riches.
Ça m'a déçu,
parce que je redoutais notamment
de découvrir avec cet indice
que seuls les pays riches peuvent aider
les pays pauvres.
Ce n'est pas le cas.
Et d'ailleurs, un peu plus bas,
je n'ai pas la diapo sur moi, vous verrez
quelque chose qui m'a vraiment réjoui,
c'est que le Kenya est dans le top 30,
et ça prouve une chose très, très importante :
ce n'est pas l'argent qui compte.
C'est l'attitude.
C'est la culture.
C'est un gouvernement et un peuple qui veulent contribuer
au reste du monde
et qui ont de l'imagination et le courage
de se tourner vers les autres, plutôt que de ne penser qu'à eux.
Je vais vite passer les autres diapos
pour vous montrer les pays moins bien classés.
On a l'Allemagne en 13e place, les États-Unis à la 21e place,
le Mexique à la 66e place,
et là on a des pays en voie de développement
comme la Russie à la 95e place, ou la Chine à la 107e place.
Pour les pays comme la Chine, la Russie ou l'Inde,
qui se trouve à peu près au même niveau,
en quelque sorte, ça ne m'étonne pas.
Ils ont passé beaucoup de temps
récemment, à construire leur propre économie,
leur propre société et leur propre constitution.
Mais on peut espérer
que leur croissance
se tournera ensuite plus vers l'extérieur
que ça a été le cas jusqu'à présent.
On peut aussi se pencher sur chaque pays
pour voir toutes ses données en détail.
Vous y aurez accès
à partir de ce soir, minuit, sur goodcountry.org,
pour consulter les détails.
Vous pouvez même voir le niveau de chaque donnée individuelle.
Donc ça, c'est l'indice des bons pays.
Ça sert à quoi ?
Eh bien, il existe car je veux essayer
d'injecter le mot « bon »,
ou de le réinjecter, dans la conversation.
J'en ai assez d'entendre parler de compétitivité.
J'en ai assez d'entendre parler
de prospérité, de richesse, de croissance rapide.
J'en ai assez d'entendre parler de pays heureux
parce que ça reste quand même égoïste.
Nous restons tournés vers nous-mêmes,
et si on continue comme ça,
nous aurons de gros, gros problèmes.
Je crois qu'on sait tous
ce qu'on veut entendre.
On veut entendre parler de bons pays,
et je vais d'ailleurs vous demander un petit service.
C'est pas grand chose.
Ce sera peut-être facile à faire,
peut-être même agréable
ou même utile :
c'est de commencer à employer le mot « bon »
dans ce contexte.
Quand vous pensez à votre propre pays,
quand vous pensez aux pays des autres,
quand vous pensez à des sociétés,
quand vous parlez du monde d'aujourd'hui,
mettez-vous à employer ce mot
de la façon dont j'en ai parlé ce soir.
Pas « bon », le contraire de « mauvais »,
parce que c'est trop subjectif.
Mais « bon », le contraire d' « égoïste »,
pour qualifier un pays qui s'intéresse aux intérêts de tous.
J'aimerais que vous essayiez,
que ce mot devienne le bâton
qui s'abattrait sur nos politiciens.
Quand vous élisez, que vous les réélisez,
que vous votez pour eux,
que vous écoutez ce qu'ils vous proposent,
employez ce mot, « bon »,
et posez-vous la question :
« Est-ce qu'un bon pays ferait ça ? »
Et si la réponse est non, méfiez-vous.
Posez-vous la question : « C'est ça, le comportement
de mon pays ? »
« Est-ce que je veux venir d'un pays
où le gouvernement, en mon nom,
fait de telles choses ?
Ou est-ce que je préfère plutôt
voyager aux quatre coins du monde
la tête haute, en me disant
que je suis fier d'être originaire d'un bon pays ? »
Et tout le monde vous accueillera.
Et tout le monde, avant de dormir,
quelques secondes avant de sombrer, se dira :
« Mince, heureusement qu'il y a ce pays. »
Je pense que c'est ça, au bout du compte,
qui fera changer les choses.
Ce mot, « bon »,
et le nombre 6,8
ainsi que la découverte qui se cache derrière
ont changé ma vie.
Ils peuvent changer votre vie,
et ils peuvent nous permettre de changer
le comportement des politiciens et des sociétés,
et ainsi, nous pourrons changer le monde.
La façon dont je vois mon pays
a changé depuis que je pense à ces choses-là.
Avant, je voulais vivre dans un pays riche,
et puis j'ai voulu vivre dans un pays heureux,
mais j'ai ensuite compris que ça ne suffisait pas.
Je ne veux pas vivre dans un pays riche.
Je ne veux pas vivre dans un pays
en forte croissance, ou dans un pays compétitif.
Je veux vivre dans un bon pays.
Et j'espère vraiment que vous aussi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)